I knew the morning of the 26th that
there was something wrong you could feel
it it was just a sea of fire coming over
the hill burning into the city
from the hospital you could see almost
the whole entire thing
my name is Edd's wada I am a staff
physician at Mercy Medical Center I
provide care for kidney patients and ICU
patients my name is Kenneth Luke I am
the disaster infectious diseases and
basestation coordinator the fire took on
the life of its own
we kept hearing that this fire was
continuing to spread this is a city of
around 90,000 people 30,000 people were
evacuated the red area on this map is
the complete burn from the fire with the
winds being so high and so fast it
actually blew embers over to the other
side of the river which was were a
majority of the homes were burned
I finally planted those roses in the
front of the house and after the fire
they were a puddle of melted plastic
that was what was left of our house I
knew there'd be damage but total
destruction
people were surprised that IDI went back
to work the next day you can't sit
around and mope all that's left now is
the president in future that's not a bad
thing human kindness was displayed
throughout this whole entire event many
many staff lost their homes or evacuated
and just came to work because they knew
that the patients still need to be taken
care of they knew that the community
still needed us from an administration
to a staff they're gonna find a way to
help and they did we set up an Employee
Assistance Program we had a lot of
counselors to come in and set up regular
counseling they set up funds to help
reimburse employees to get them back on
their feet they do supplies available
made some support available make some
money available anybody who has
evacuated anybody who lost their home
they helped them out why are we here if
it's not to help each other human
kindness I think is the responsibility
of every person on this planet
[Music]